[Music]
all right Dean we are here at Jingle
Ball is this your first ever jingle ball
first-ever jingle ball I'm excited
excited I'm a Taylor pan but I'm also
not like big into the top 20 like
Billboard hits so this is like like I
like it cheering and I like Taylor Swift
I don't really know much else what's
going on I gotta ask you bachelor Winter
Games yeah you guys leave tomorrow or
those who are doing it to leave tomorrow
well are you leaving tomorrow are you
going to Vermont no tomorrow I'm gonna
be at the beach so I'm probably gonna be
getting breakfast with my roommates yeah
you can confirm you are not
participating I will neither confirm nor
deny you never know they might switch it
up last second and send me out there yes
I think you are doing it are you on the
hunt are you looking for love yeah yeah
absolutely I mean yeah we all right
Kristina a lot of fans out there still
rooting for some sort of reconciliation
yeah
no Christine is amazing she deserves
absolute best and we're not together but
I wish her the best do you think in the
future you guys could reconcile in some
capacity I mean anything's possible
right but I don't know we both care a
lot about each other so I would say
that's you know never never close the
door fully on anything I guess you go
you gotta reach in here Jingle Ball the
kiss under the mistletoe this season who
do I plan to kiss under the mistletoe
make another one I'll put that one back
in there
are you naughty or nice on this list are
you on the naughty or nice list this
year in Hawaii I'm on the naughty list
this year probably
but next year you'll be on the nice list
let's try for the nice list next year
yeah thank you so much